[Music]
okay everyone I'm excited because I'm
with Boris who plays Uncle George
himself how you doing good I'm very good
dude this season is another great season
and you're still one of the most scary
characters on this show you do such a
good job so is there like do you just
get a throw out of playing the villain
in the show absolutely I mean it's
interesting you've changed the villain
because I mean obviously you never think
of yourself as a villain
and I think maybe by the end of it
you're not really sure who the villain
is which is great
um I get an absolute thrill it's so much
fun I mean it's crazy right yeah it is
crazy and it's cool because people see
with season four like you have this
great great uh grand entrance in it so
are you satisfied with how Uncle
George's story is gonna rap are you as
an actor satisfied with it yes except
for the fact that we can't continue
but yeah no it's really cool
is there anything from doing the show
for Four Seasons that you'll take away
the most with you from this experience
that you'll go on the rest of your
career
well certainly in my mind there's so
many moments where I got to do something
just way back to the first season when I
got to
squeeze the juice out of them
find a crooked piece of chicken
I got to enter with
crowd between my toes
and who knows maybe worms in my teeth
but so yeah I mean look that guy stop
sticks with you I love that and do you
yourself like will you go watch all the
episodes of season four are you kind of
just tune in here and there I like I I
I've had to wait I have had to wait a
bit to watch it so you're excited for
the premiere tonight this is crazy
always fun yeah yeah it's good to be
back in person and uh yeah I wish you
the best of luck thanks for talking to
me it's a pleasure hey Barbara how you
doing
um so this is amazing and I'm excited
for you because the first season on the
show and people are gonna fall in love
with your character so was it that as
exciting for you jumping on set that
first day
oh that first day was a terror
I mean please do we sleep you know it's
like some I couldn't
I could not find my way
Tiffany would come down and she'd say
Barbara you're invited to set oh my God
you know I have to go she goes it's so
much better when we ask tell you you're
invited I could not remember the way to
get to this set okay so did you tap into
that Terror for when you were playing in
a horror show like this
no
truly live in the moment now later on I
will look at this whole event and go hmm
was there something I maybe should have
said differently I don't know I truly
just live I live in a moment they
allowed me to to do that and somebody I
also live to make adjustments for you
that I think I can say in all honesty is
one of my strong suits I'll give you my
gut and Paul San Diego Barbara
have you thought could we try that all
right let's do that that's great okay
yeah yeah and people see that with your
character because there is so much it's
clearly got to be comedic improving
going on because you bring a lot of
humor to the show that's great so was
that something made clear for you too
that you were going to bring a lot of
Comedy into this part no absolutely not
in fact when I auditioned
for it you know there was Bobby and Bev
I auditioned for Bev the part that Denny
Dillon was playing and she auditioned
for about we had no idea why we were
playing the other one and it became
clear to me you know once we started
shooting I thought well they they know
they know what uh what the road they're
on and I'll just follow and and do that
I'm kind of a Cheesy human being anyway
so you have to tone me down you know
they're saying oh just be yourself
Barbara be a little less than yourself
that would be good so yeah that comedy
thing yeah no and I love to you
mentioned Denny because what makes it so
special is that both of you seem like
you've known each other forever is that
the case if you guys worked together
before
no we'd never met before in our lives no
and we're so very different and I can't
speak for Denny but I certainly adore
her you know she's she's so helpful
she's so present she's got a Whimsical
uh sense about her and even when
well you don't see us together on camera
or you
we're right there for each other she's
that's your dream
that your partner actually is your
partner I love that and it translates
onto the screen and people are gonna
adore you in this show so can't wait for
him to see it everybody check out the
servant Premiere this Friday thanks so
much Barbara for your time thank you
good so I love your character of snake
so what's really interesting about your
character though coming into last season
was it's interesting that you have a lot
of screen time with the character of
Leanne so what was it like working with
Nella and like having that experience on
Steph for the first time
well it was really uh really generous
from her she was a very generous actor
very down to earth like I've been saying
right before very very open-minded not
at all with an ego so right away when we
were you know there it's as if we were
friends like we were ready and I was
almost you know taken aback by that
because I tend to be more quiet in the
beginning it's just very given very down
to earth and so it was so welcoming that
I couldn't really you know no that's
great to hear and what's also
interesting about your characters I feel
like your character is always outside is
there any scenes you have indoors and
are you ever like cold out there are you
always dealing with the weather
I'm inside a lot but you know you'll see
so did you feel like going into a show
that's on a big service like Apple TV
plus did you feel more pressure jumping
on that or were you able to kind of like
tune that noise out you mean because I'm
a nobody and
no not at all
no it was really
it's out you know and yeah I did have a
lot of adrenaline I was also I was just
talking about that before on how you
know I was during the covet and so we
all had masked and communication was
quite shut down so I was a bit myself
shut down but aside from that uh now
what's your question again no I'm just
saying like was that like something you
had to like tune out pressure from being
on a big streaming show Big Show no
definitely also because you know it's
the presence of such Geniuses and I know
how great they are that obviously you
know I wanna I Wanna Be You Know
leveling up so I had a lot of pressure
that I'm good at putting on myself very
often you know that's not a problem I do
that a lot so yeah I freaked out no but
it doesn't come off the way you do an
amazing job and excited for people to
see you kill it in season four thank you
so much for talking to me today thank
you thank you thank you